the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so today we're gonna get into the most
politically and emotionally fraught
topic of this course for stuff on
chemical and biological effects of
radiation now that you know the units of
dose background dose we're gonna talked
about what ionizing radiation does in
the body to cells to other things and
we're gonna get into a lot of the
feelings associated with it and by the
end of this lecture or Thursday I'm
gonna teach you guys how to smell
[ __ ] because we're gonna go through
one of millions of Internet articles
about things that cause cancer that
don't cause cancer in this case it's
gonna be radiation from cellphones so
I'm gonna try to reserve at least 10
minutes at the end of this class for us
to go through a bunch of quote-unquote
studies and misinterpretations of those
conclusions and I was going to pick my
favorite of the 44 studies and looking
through them all my favorite are all of
them so we'll see how many we can get
through but let's get into the science
first so you can understand a bit about
what goes on with ionizing radiation
like radiation damage in materials
radiation damage and biological systems
is an extremely multi time scale process
everything from the physical stage or
the ballistic stage of radiation damage
to biological tissues acting on
femtoseconds where this is just the
physical knocking about of atoms and
creation of free radicals these ionized
species which in metals you wouldn't
care about and biological organisms you
do because then they undergo chemical
reactions from the initial movement and
creation of other strange radio lytic
species and the diffusion and reaction
of those things which happens starts and
finishes in about a microsecond before
most of these things are neutralized and
then later on the build-up of those
oxidative byproducts of these chemical
reactions undergo the biological stages
of radiation damage like all of the free
radicals with biological molecules have
reacted within a millisecond so
radiation goes in a millisecond later
the damage is done then you start to
affect let's say cell division it takes
on average minutes for a rapidly
dividing cell to undergo a division
that's when the effects would first be
manifest
DNA mutation but then it take things
like weeks or years for these sorts of
things to manifest in a health related
aspect so the division of one cancer a
cell into two won't change the way your
body functions but the doubling in size
of a tumor that blocks are there tissue
absolutely would and so it all starts in
this sub femtosecond regime when most of
you well you know for this entire year
we've been approximating humans as water
we're gonna continue to do so for the
purposes of these biological effects so
let's say you a giant sack of water gets
irradiated by a gamma ray and that gamma
ray undergoes Compton scattering which
now you know how to tell what the energy
of the Compton electron would be we
never talked about what happens to the
molecule where it came from that
molecule remains ionized and since
you're not especially electrically
conductive they are not neutralized
immediately and you can be left over
with either a free radical or an
electron in an excited state and then
what happens next is the whole basis of
radiation damage to biological organisms
these free radicals can then encounter
other ones and let's say an h2o plus can
very quickly find a neighboring water
molecule which they're almost touching
and form o H and h3o this is better
known as h plus and that Oh H is a kind
of unstable molecule and these excited
electrons here can also become these h2o
pluses leading to this cascade of what
we call radiolysis reactions there's a
few of them listed here things like an O
h plus an aqueous electron which could
come from anywhere
like Compton scattering like any other
biological process that frees an
electron could make another o H - so you
can locally change the pH inside the
cell that you happen to be a radiating
or let's say any of these oxidative
byproducts could encounter DNA rip off
or add an electron to one of the guanine
thymine or other 2 or 3 bases and DNA or
RNA then you've changed the genetic code
of the cell and the progression of these
radiolysis byproducts like I mentioned
whether you go by excitation or
ionization
you start to build up these six speech
these five species tend to be or these
six ones tend to be the ending
byproducts of a whole host of radiolysis
reactions and don't worry you're never
gonna have to memorize all the
radiolysis reactions because the
mechanism math is fairly complicated and
there are multiple routes to creating
each one but the ones that are
highlighted here in these squares are
the ones that end up building up in your
body
things like peroxide has anyone ever put
peroxide on a wound before what happens
yellow no bubbles up what happens when
you form peroxide in your body from
radiation well luckily luckily it
doesn't quite bubble up on the
macroscale level but it does it is a
vigorous oxidizer 90% h2o to is used as
rocket fuel as the oxidizing species in
rocket fuel
you don't make 90% h2o to from getting
irradiated but every molecule counts
things like oh - you're shifting the
amount of oxygen in the cells and then
there's things like these superoxide
radicals or h2o - h2o plus or all these
other things that are available to rip
off or add an electron to something else
that normally wouldn't have it and the
list of these potential reactions as
well as their equilibrium constants and
activation energy is huge here's half of
it notice a lot of these equilibrium
constants shift really strongly one way
or the other so just because these
molecules are made doesn't mean that all
of them end up staying and doing damage
but unless these rate constants are
either zero or infinity there's going to
be some dynamic equilibrium of these
reactions so once in a while some of
these free radicals will escape the
cloud of chemical change in charge and
get to something else here's the other
half of the equation set and it's under
debate just how many of these reactions
there actually are like how often would
you - radicals combine with water what
you can see is not quite said in the
reaction to form 802 - and o - n H+ kind
of a strange little reaction right there
actually a lot of them are quite strange
you don't usually think of them
happening because these are very
transient reactions whose byproducts do
build up and that's the chemical basis
for radiation damage to biological
tissues now once those chemical process
products form they have to move or
diffuse so you can actually calculate or
get diffusion coefficients for some of
these oxidizing species as well as
compute an average radius that they'll
will move before undergoing a reaction
so this is part of the basis for why
alpha radiation is a lot more damaging
than gamma radiation chances are if you
incorporate an alpha emitter into the
cell it does a whole bunch of damage
that damage consists of these oxidative
chemical species that if they're that
far away from neighboring atoms that
happen to be in DNA they might do some
damage whereas isolated compton scatters
and photoelectric excitations from gamma
radiation not so much
chances are you hit random water in the
cell that isn't quite close to anything
fragile and not much happens but you can
also see this by looking at charged
particle tracks these things can
actually be experimentally measured by
firing electrons into gel or film or
something like that you can actually see
tracks of ionization and watch them as a
function of time in this case it's a
simulation of a charged particle track
at different time scales so right here
this 10 to the minus 12 or the time in
seconds tells you where these radiolysis
products are and the N number here tells
you how many of those remain so after a
picosecond you can pretty much just
trace out the path that the electron
took starts off right here what do you
guys notice about the density of the
charge particle track as it moves from
the source to the end
it's much more dense at the end and why
do you think that is okay more than just
yeah stopping power yes but fill in the
beginning and end of that sentence Chris
you had your hand up that's right
so you're actually visualizing the
change in stopping power as a function
of charge particle energy it comes in
has a very high energy and it might
knock a little radiation damage cascade
by hitting another electron which can
have its own shower of ionization and
then it moves while doing nothing in
this straight line until it hits another
one and notice right at the end that's
where the densest amount of damage is
done because that's where the stopping
power is the highest it's also where the
energy is the lowest so this is where
the worlds of bio and physics collide
you can actually visualize stopping
power
like actually visual visually in gel or
on film or on a computer by watching
these charged particle tracks and after
10 to the minus 12 seconds all the
ballistics are over then you end up with
diffusion and reaction so it's going to
be a balance between these charged
particles moving away from each other
and finding something else or finding
each other and recombining and that's
why as you go up in time scale the
particle tracks get more and more
diffuse and the number of these
remaining free radicals goes down until
you level out at about a microsecond
when all of the different particles are
so spread out that there are none
touching each other anymore to refresh
your memory a bit from a few seconds ago
take a look at some of the charge states
of these oxidative byproducts some of
them plus some of the - some of them
excited all over the place so they can
react with each other which is something
you'd want to encourage so that they
don't go and find something else causing
biological damage there's a question on
last year's OCW problem set that I'm not
giving you for this one which is
calculate the radiation resistance you
would get by getting cryogenically
frozen so here's a question that I don't
think a lot of cryo genisys ask
themselves if you want to preserve a
human for 10,000
and wake them up later how much
radiation damage you're gonna get every
think there's a cryogenic sister -
themselves that question I don't
actually know but it's not a question
I've ever heard before which is why I
made it a problem set question because I
know the answer is not out there
I looked for a while let's switch
particles for a second look at the
charge particle tracks from a proton
what differences do you see between the
proton and the electron charge particle
track so proton electron proton electron
here's what it's straight why do you
think it's straight why does anyone
think it's straight they are bigger more
massive so the same deflection the same
transfer of momentum to an electron
using our beloved hollow cylinder
approximation thing causes less of a
change in direction for a proton as it
does an electron the forces are the same
they're both just a plus or minus one
hitting a plus or minus one charge but
the mass is quite different on the
proton so it doesn't get deflected as
much which is why the charged particle
tracks are so straight now what are
these things here what are those
offshoots
they're secondary charged particle
tracks so let's say a proton hits an
electron that electron can have any
amount of energy probably going to be
lower than the proton did and it's going
to cause its own little damage cascade
right there and just like before you can
track the amount of the number of these
charged particle tracks moving from
5,000 to about 1000 between let's say 10
picoseconds and a little less than a
microsecond and once these charged
particles have spread out or diffused
away chances are recombination has gone
down quite a bit and they're going to go
react with other things and this is a
perfect analogy to radiation damage in
metals so radiation damage and biology
is like radiation damage and material
science you have this initial cluster of
damage in materials it's usually
vacancies or interstitials in biology
it's charged particles but when they're
in a dense cascade they can recombine
with each other and the ones that miss
each other go off to find either other
defects in the material or other atoms
in your cells it's a very fitting
analogy yeah
let's see I don't know if we see the
whole charge particle track here you're
right it doesn't look like the density
changes very much it can't even really
tell where the sources we may not be
looking at the whole thing here's
another question so it's a two MeV
proton that scale bar is 0.1 microns
let's do a quick simulation to verify
this idea luckily we have the tools to
do this as soon as I clone my screen
let's use rim and find out what is the
range of 2 MeV protons in water and if
it's more than about a micron which is
what's shown let's say that's 2 microns
if it's more than 2 microns what's shown
on the screen means we're not seeing the
whole track rim good you can see it so
let's say hydrogen at 2 MeV going into
something consisting of H and O in a
ratio of 2 to 1 make sure its density is
correct for room temperature water and
let's look at a range of 25 microns
because I kind of already know the
answer much more than 25 microns so our
initial assertion was correct let's
actually find out what the range is 40
microns whoa that's a little more than I
thought
protons and water at just 2 MeV
let's fly tons of them we get about a
thousand look at the range make it
bigger so you can read it 75 microns 75
point 5 micron range so there you go
let's go back to the big one so there
you go if this scale bar is 0.1 microns
you're looking about two of the 75
microns of charge particle track
interesting no one picked up that
question last year but I'm glad you did
I'm glad you're able to we were able to
show you where it comes from so this
would look quite different if you're
looking at the end of the charged
particle track cool good question to
look really really close up you see a
lot more of this branching again
so whenever a proton strikes let's say
another atom or an electron you get your
own little dense damage cascade and look
at that not much until the very end and
you get this cloud of damage popping off
at the end so yet more examples of the
physics that you've learned popping up
in biological systems the difference is
its water not metal but otherwise
everything's the same and then we get to
what's called G values I don't know why
it's called G but I'll tell you what
they mean it's the number of each
species per hundred MeV found later at
let's say 0.28 microseconds are
typically one microsecond for different
particles of various energies these are
relative effectiveness --is of these
particles at different energies to leave
oxidative byproducts by so there's a few
things that are wrapped up into these G
values so notice that for in this case
there's a G value for electron energy at
different energies you'll have different
amounts of Oh H or h3o and such per
hundred evie of energy so the conative G
values here it's like number of chemical
species per hundred e v of energy so
it's an energy normalized measure of the
effectiveness of radiation making
chemicals does that make sense to folks
if not raise your hand I'll try to
re-explain okay
yep so a G value it's goat's got units
in concentration per unit energy and
it's a measure of how many chemicals a
given particle will make as a function
of its energy and these particles are
the ones that survive the recombination
and end up diffusing to other species so
these G values it's kind of like how
many oxidative speed
she's our maid that go off and damage
other things let's look at some trends
right here for things like o H for
electrons
what sort of patterns do you notice in
the data and take a sec to parse some of
these numbers just look at the top three
rows what pattern do you see starts high
goes low goes high again why do you
think that is straight from the physics
at super low energies a hundred evey
electron you'll make an average one o H
radical for every hundred Evie of energy
as you increase in energy you start
making fewer and fewer per unit energy
actually that's not the one I want to
look at that's a different species let's
see no that is okay that follows the
pattern that we're looking for
oh yeah this is just total number from
everything right it's just a number of
each chemical species left over after a
microsecond so what do you think could
cause this initial increase and then
decrease and then increase part of it
the cross sections that also go into the
stopping power that's part of the answer
so at really low energies you're already
at your stopping power peak and that way
for the little bit of energy you have
chances are it's going to ionize
different things then as you increase
your energy you have more and more of
that range of the particle in the lower
stopping power region so you'll have
more of those e you'll have more and
more of that particle Colette's limit
let me try and phrase this quite well
let's go back to the charged particle
tracks for electrons and I'll get this
yeah here we go so when your electron
comes in at really really low energy
you're in that region right there
chances are you're going to make a lot
of those oxidative byproducts and then
as you go a little higher in energy
you make fewer per unit distance you
make fewer per unit energy you can think
of that as the spread right there but
then also as you go way higher in energy
your ability to ionize increases so
you've got that sort of 1 over e term in
stopping power slowing thing making
things worse and you've got that log of
e term and stopping power making things
better and if we go back to the data
right here for this top 3 or 4 it tends
to follow that trend pretty well now
what about things like h2o 2 what sort
of trend do you see there the opposite
so since I'll give you a hint h2o 2
isn't directly made by radiolysis it
tends to occur by reaction of other
radiolysis products so it's like a
secondary chemical not a primary
produced chemical so why do you think
h2o 2 follows the opposite trend
sure yeah so to rephrase what Sarah said
in this energy range right here you're
producing this fairly dense cascade of
oxidative byproducts when those
reactions occur they tend to make things
like h2o to something that's not made
directly from radiolysis but indirectly
from recombination of those chemicals
and then as you raise the energy more
and more to like 20 kV you start making
those primary products more spread out
they're not as close to each other they
don't recombine as much they don't make
as much h2o to they'll tend instead to
spread out a little more so more will
survive more of these primary ones will
survive and not react to make as many of
the secondary ones so how is that
explanation fitting with you guys cool
so it's a balance between at
intermediate energies you make a whole
lot of primary ones which are so close
that they react to make the secondary
species much more easily as you raise
the energy of the particles going in you
make more isolated primaries that can't
find each other and they don't make as
many secondaries per unit energy yeah
it shows you it's less because wouldn't
since it's making a lot of the initial
primary you might accept at very low
energies our idea of stopping power
isn't quite as complete so what other by
what other processes can electrons lose
energy at really low energies you could
have a deflection without an ionization
right just a simple let's say you could
have an excitation you can have just
Coulomb deflection you can have
neutralization you can have all those
really really low energy things that go
on that don't end up producing as many
ionizations because you need to produce
an ionization or an excitation to kick
off radiolysis so then when you get high
enough in energy and chances are you'll
ionize rather than undergo one of these
really low energy and loss mechanisms
then you start making more of the
primaries but densely which make more of
the secondaries then as you go even
higher in energy
you still make tons of primaries but
since they're spread out more since the
stopping power is lower they don't find
each other and they don't make as many
secondaries so let's look at some other
numbers and trends different particles
first of all for protons and for alpha
particles note here that the scales are
in MeV whereas the G values for
electrons in the sort of ke V range and
for protons and the MeV range are pretty
much the same on the same order of
magnitude anyone have any idea why
they're heavier and then what does that
lead to in terms of a stopping power
they're actually harder to stop if
they're heavier then the deflection of
an electron doesn't stop them as much
and so that way more of these proton and
alpha radiolysis products are going to
be more spread out so you get the same
number per hundred MeV in the MeV range
as you do for electrons at a much lower
energy but then alphas are also had this
interesting thing that they're doubly
charged so that they are those Coulomb
forces remember it's by Z squared so
it's four times as strong so let's see
how do they compare yeah there are
really enough data to draw those nice
trends that you could see from electrons
but we do have some other interesting
trends in the G values as a function of
temperature so these right here are G
values for H and O H by gamma rays which
are two primary species and here we've
grasped them as a function of
temperature why do you think the G
values or the amount of radiolysis
products that survive a microsecond
increase with temperature what's this a
competing force or a balance between
so once these creates once these
products are made what are the two
things that they can do anyone recombine
or defuse good what which of these will
increase much more strongly with
temperature diffusion if they spread out
more at higher temperature then they'll
separate from each other and not
recombine as much so a whole bunch will
be made no matter what in a matter of
femtoseconds but at a higher temperature
more of them diffuse away from each
other and survive the Cascade rather
than recombining and so that's why when
you look at any primary species h2 or H
or anything like that you're going to
see an increase in G values with
temperature what do you guys think is
gonna happen to these secondary
byproducts with temperature decrease and
why do you say so
yeah if the primary ones are surviving
more you're not going to make as many
secondary ones and that's just what we
see number of free electrons left or
especially things like the amount of
h2o2 it's all going to be in balance and
if more primary survive you don't make
as many secondaries as a function of
temperature one these heavy ones are
slower to diffuse but - they're not made
as much because the primaries escape
each others pull and go off the damage
something else in a reactor this would
be metals causing oxidation in a body
this would be you and so let's get into
the materials aspect of this to give you
a more let's you know less biologically
damaging view of what can radiolysis
really do it's quite relevant to all
reactors including the Fukushima reactor
the idea there is that the reactor was
flooded with seawater which introduces
chlorine which greatly changes the
balance of Radiologic byproducts and
this can actually be directly studied
there's an experiment just a few years
ago two years ago where they wanted to
figure out what is the influence of
radiolysis on corrosion if you're making
all these H's and O H minuses and h2o
pluses does it change the corrosion rate
of materials in the reactor so they
built a high pressure cell that they
fill with high pressure high temperature
water and they've got this little disk
of metal with a thin membrane right
there it's thin enough that protons can
pass through it and cause radiolysis to
occur right in this little pocket where
the water is and so where the protons
are you get radiolysis
where the protons aren't you get regular
old water corrosion and the results are
pretty astounding you can see the
irradiated zone in extra oxide thickness
so you can see where the protons work
because radiolysis sped up the corrosion
rate as a single effect right nearby not
hundred microns away was the same water
at the same temperature and pressure
just no protons and no radiolysis to
look at a cross-section you can very
clearly
see the difference in oxide thickness
way out in the on irradiated zone or in
the irradiated zone and you can tell
right here how many protons there were
until right over here where there were
none so it's a very striking example of
well this is what radiolysis does in
reactors and we actually do things in
reactors to suppress radiolysis we
inject hydrogen gas though there's a
hydrogen gas overpressure injected one
of the main reasons is to suppress
radiolysis because if I jump back to any
of these reactions a lot of them involve
h2 and if you dump a whole bunch of h2
into the reactor you push the reaction
backwards in the other direction from
straight-up chemistry if you add a
reactant or I add a product you push the
equilibrium in the other direction
that's why we do this in terms of
injecting hydrogen into light water
reactors and if you look at the amount
of hydrogen injected in a in a PWR a
pressurized water reactor which
comprises two-thirds of the reactors in
the country it's like 20 to 30 cubic
centimeters per kilogram of dissolved
hydrogen that's quite a bit and the
whole idea there is to suppress
radiolysis and suppress corrosion so I
find it'd be pretty cool so a knowledge
of G values can keep your reactor from
corroding then let's get into the
biological effects in the end for the
for the long-term effect it's all about
what happens to DNA because if a cell
mutates it can either kill the cell so
that it can't replicate or you can cause
a mutation that might make some sort of
a change and change the cell's function
and so you may imagine if a lot of this
stuff is done in le t linear energy
transfer again another word for stopping
power if you look at the density of
these damage cascades as a function of
stopping power le T you can see that for
high energy electrons or beta particles
they just bounce around with a lot of
distance between interactions causing
very relatively little damage on the way
for O'Shay electrons again electrons but
at a much lower energy there at the end
of their stopping power curve
and they caused a lot more damage
wherever they're emitted because already
they're gonna make a much denser damage
cascade alpha particles just go slamming
through it's like rolling a tank through
yourself pretty much because there's
gonna be a ton of interactions from
charge particle interactions you won't
really change the path of that alpha
because an electron imparts very little
momentum to an alpha particle and if DNA
happens to be in the way it's gonna get
damaged this is a lot of the reason why
there is relative effectiveness of
different types of radiation we talked
last week about these quality factors
gamma rays are one electrons tend to be
pretty close to one alphas tend to be
twenty because the same energy alpha
particle will impart a ton more damage
locally than the same energy beta
particle so can you guys see visually
where these quality factors come from
cool and there's two types of DNA damage
direct and indirect direct damage is
what you might think radiation comes in
and ionizes something in the DNA either
causing let's say a tooth I mean based
bridge like a kink in the DNA or
destroying it or doing anything but most
of the damage is done indirectly because
the amount of volume of DNA in your
cells is extremely low does anyone ever
done the old high school bio experiment
where you extract DNA from onions
strawberries anything so how did you do
it anyone remember how this was done
so you take let's say an onion mix it in
solution with a bunch of stuff and you
end up with this gigantic booger which
happens to be DNA it's like a three-foot
it's not thing but what was the volume
of the DNA compared to the volume of the
onion it's quite small there's not a lot
of DNA in cells so the direct damage
route while still there comprises very
little of the damage done to tissue
mostly it's indirect because surrounding
all DNA is the rest of your cellular
fluid which consists mostly of water and
as we've seen all today water undergoes
radiolysis those radio lytic byproducts
can diffuse find their way to DNA and
cause the same sort of ionization that
direct radiation would do and since that
volume is much larger let's say the
hollow cylinder of water surrounding
your DNA this is the most likely route
to cellular damage and actually I want
to skip ahead to something real quick
you can actually use that to your
advantage because it can kill tumor
cells so tumors are rapidly dividing
masses of cancer cells if those cells
are rapidly dividing then DNA is being
replicated much more readily so you can
inject something that will bind to DNA
like this little chemical right here
this iodine 125 whatever whatever which
mimics thymidine something that would be
found near DNA but absorbs radiation
much better so you can inject this
iodine containing organic molecule which
binds somehow to DNA I'm not going to
even guess how it works but if you want
this to get damaged then you want let's
say your DNA to get preferably damaged
the tumors are replicating faster
they're going to incur more damage from
the same amount of radiation so the same
process that causes cancer can be used
to cure cancer interestingly enough and
so good we have we do have about 10 or
12 minutes to talk pseudoscience so now
that you know a little bit about how
radiation can cause cancer and mutations
and you know a lot of the physics behind
how much energy do you need to cause an
ionization
let's start knocking off these questions
one by one so this field more than any
is fraught with garbage absolute garbage
science I won't even say pseudoscience
because that almost makes it sound half
legit garbage misinterpretations lies
poorly done studies misinterpretations
of abstracts and conclusions and today
I'd like to focus on cell phones and do
they cause cancer very hot topic there's
lots of people with predetermined
agendas that want to say all
electromagnetic radiation is bad and we
should go back to an agrarian society
where nothing happened well I'll give
you a hint Cambodia tried that and it
didn't turn out too well
people have interesting notions of
what's real and what's not so let's
start looking at some of these there's
an article written by this fellow Lloyd
Burrell around November 2014 which looks
like it was republished somewhere in
2016 let's just start looking at the
effects so what I want to start doing
here is cultivating your nose to be able
to smell [ __ ] because this is a lot
of what you're going to be doing in
terms of public outreach as nuclear
scientist you will be called on to
provide expert advice and say whether
things are real or not explain why and
do it in an empathetic way so as not to
make people feel stupid because it's
very easy for someone to read this and
think yeah I should be afraid cell
phones cause cancer it's a natural
reaction to feel let's take a look at
some of these facts cell phones emit
microwave radio frequency radiation true
or false
true yeah these are microwave emitters
they're RF emitters what sort of energy
is microwave radiation a minute I just
give me an order of magnitude MeV evey
ke V little MeV fractions of an Eevee
it's far beyond the visible range in the
lower energy spectrum can a milli
electron volt photon cause an ionization
directly no microwaves and RF are na na
na is the ionizing radiation they can
cook things by heating up water but they
do not cause ionizations the way that
ionizing radiation does this radiation
has an ability to penetrate our bodies
true or false true it gets through us
right radio waves are going through us
all the time our governments do
virtually nothing to protect us from
these dangers technically true yeah so
this is a classic example of
fear-mongering taking a bunch of facts
putting them together to elicit an
emotional response that is incorrect and
because the emotional part of the brain
kicks in far faster than logical part of
the brain that's how we're wired it
elicits a reaction with a predetermined
conclusion and yet there is strong
evidence multiple peer-reviewed studies
I'm not even gonna read the rest of the
sentence because I don't want to go on
record saying it as if it were true
let's instead look at the studies
because that is the stuff that we should
trust initial 44 studies cited and let's
look at some of the reasons let's see
there's a little bit have to make it a
little smaller can you guys still read
that at the back or actually you know
you know make a little bigger and forget
the side bar yeah that's better
okay I was gonna pick a couple of these
to show you and I started going through
them and my favorite ones are all of
them most of the studies are perfectly
legitimate some of them are not most of
the interpretations by this Lloyd fellow
are absolutely wrong and either done
ignorantly which somewhat forgivable it
can be hard to parse these studies or
intentionally we don't know which one
let's look
here telecoms giant etc commissioned an
independent study 404 not found let's go
to the next one we can't conclude
anything from that the Interphone study
found that regular cellphone use
significantly increased the risk of
gliomas some type of tumour by 40%
the 1640 hours or more of use let's look
at the key figure taken from this paper
and blow it up so you can see it what do
you guys notice about this figure okay
forget the low-resolution we can't knock
Doc's it might be a copy no error bars
and what does most of this cell phone
use and the the unit not shown here is
let's I think it's like hours of use
yeah except for this one blue line is
odds ratio a lot of these things are
given in Oro or odds ratio let's say the
fractional or let's say the multiplying
factor for increased risk of finding
cancer in the variable group compared to
the control group and control and
variable are interesting topics I want
to make sure people have so we have the
Interphone study cited in many of these
papers let's say okay garbage garbage
opinions opinions let's go find the
study this is something I wish people
did more is go to the study itself yeah
the Interphone study
they make this bigger to make it more
obvious so many people this articles
been sighted almost 500 times I don't
know in what capacity cuz I haven't
looked up every citation but a lot of
what this site and other sites do is
cite the Interphone study to say cell
phones cause cancer read the conclusion
yes so this study is not a bogus study
the study was done correctly
reporting bars these odds ratios with
95% confidence intervals if you just
look at the numbers itself oh man 1.15
odds ratio 15% higher incidence of
cancer with a confidence interval that
includes less and more so you cannot
conclude with 95% confidence that this
data is correct and the authors very
honestly say no conclusion can be drawn
require further investigation what does
this Lloyd fellow say cancer yeah and
either accidental or deliberate
misinterpretation of the data okay let's
go to numbers two and three I don't need
those anymore let's say number two oh we
did number two number three again from
the Interphone study we can discount
that because we've now read the
conclusion of the study and look at a
bit of the difference
number four harmful association between
cell phone risk and tumors let's see
again honest authors I applaud the
authors for taking a controversial topic
doing a fair bit of data with enough at
least enough metadata analysis I think
the sample size is okay and then saying
higher level of evidence is needed what
does the internet say that takes the one
sentence that they want to support their
predetermined conclusion very dishonest
if you ask me
number five oh this is fun okay what
does number five stay huh yes it does
make me angry this is why I'm showing it
to you it's infuriating right but some
of the some of the some of the
comparisons between what the folks on
the internet will say with the sentence
that they want to say and then you go to
the actual study which they do give you
the link for a consistent pattern of
increased risk associated with wireless
phones what does the study say
take a sec to parse this I'll make a
little bigger
when you see an odds ratio of let's say
greater than one and you see a
confidence interval yeah again another
odds ratio and another confidence
interval now their odds ratio another
confidence intervals interesting the one
interesting part is for what they call
it's a lateral cumulative use which
means a tumor found on the same side of
the head as the cellphone there's
actually a confidence interval that
seems to be significant so I'm not going
to trash this study I'm going to say
it's not quite conclusive it doesn't go
out and say cell phones cause cancer
despite this fellow coming out and
saying cell phones cause cancer okay
moving on to number six was a four oh
four let's just confirm wasn't able to
get it an hour ago
oh it's back okay let's see what it does
I don't even know what this one's gonna
do
Hevy mobile phone use yeah well they'll
define that somewhere in the article so
some of these studies it's like okay
there's interesting viewpoints to be
seen they shouldn't be ignored just
because we have this predetermined
conclusion that cellphones don't cause
cancer it's important to go and actually
look at the studies and decide for
yourself let's get into the fun ones
number seven recent study on 790,000
middle-aged women found that women who
use cellphones for - and a hat for 10 or
more years we're two-and-a-half times
more likely etc etc the risk increase
with the number of years they use cell
phones let's look at the study okay
that's not the study so we need to go
find the study and that's another news
article about the study we need to go
find the study ah finally the study read
the conclusion
no I don't think so either so the best
thing that you can conclude about these
sorts of people is that they're not
reading the studies and reporting on
them if they are reading them and not
gonna get right now not everyone can
parse the science if they're reading
them understanding them and
cherry-picking the facts in order to
support their conclusion that to me
should be criminal we do live in a
country where there's freedom of speech
you're free to say whatever you want as
long as it's not hate speech of various
kinds doesn't have to be right you also
don't have to listen so just because
there are freedom to talk doesn't mean
people have an obligation to listen and
this is the problem with a lot of this
so I think my yeah my notes for this
study was just kind of the f word was
how do you get the conclusion from this
internet article of which wrote an
article about an article about an
article about a study when the
conclusion says with an excellent sample
size not associated okay let's we have
like five or seven minutes left so let's
skip ahead I had a fun one for number
twelve cancer with a pituitary gland
I'm get rid of the other stuff oh does
that look like a surprisingly familiar
figure it's another article about the
same study let's just confirm
oh look at that that right there was the
article written about the study where
the other link was an article written
about the article written about the
study okay what else next one let's just
keep going in number order it's really
study about thyroid cancer okay
this appears to be a blog so let's
search for the rear or Israel okay but
first the news article so take a sec to
parse some of this the incidence of
thyroid cancer has been increasing
rapidly in many countries including the
US Canada and Israel
I mean one thing to say let's say case
control research on this topic is
warranted sure no one's gonna no one's
gonna refute a claim that hey maybe we
should study something properly right
let's go a little further down let's try
to find the actual study where is this
study interesting the main point of this
study is that thyroid cancer and
cellphone usage are going up at the same
time this is the point where I like to
say correlation does not imply causation
and Hamor that point home by going to
one of my favorite blogs spurious
correlations you can find any dataset
that correlates with any other dataset
let's look at some examples us spending
on Science Space and Technology
correlates with a ninety nine point
seven nine percent correlation of
suicides by hanging strangulation and
suffocation correlated yes causal I
don't think so yeah
divorce rate in Maine correlates with
per-capita consumption of margarine you
can find a link between anything and
anything else if you just search the
data long enough without searching for a
mechanism or a reason so okay age of
Miss America correlates with murders by
steam hot vapors clearly we should ban
the Miss America pageant or make them
older or the other other way around make
them younger maybe this is why we have
toddlers and tiaras is to stop murders
by steam oh my god okay so this is again
the point where you have to ask yourself
what are the other confounding variables
in this study why else could thyroid
cancer be going up anyone could probably
come up with like a hundred different
possible reasons
any sort of other chemicals let's say
more industrial runoff more urbanization
smog inhalation some amount let's say I
don't know iodine released from
Chernobyl making its way through no that
would have had like 30 day half-life
yeah that's that's also gotta pretty
much decay by now yeah there could be
any number of reasons and just to say
cellphones and thyroid cancer are
correlated is like saying this what else
told oh this I think might actually have
something to there might be a link here
revenue generated by our kaise with
computer science doctorates again just a
correlation yeah look at the amazing
it's got all the same humps and
everything alright I think I've made the
point let's go on to some of the other
studies let's say number 15 out of 29
cases of neuro epithelial melters
cell phone users accounted for 11 of
them 11 of the 29 people in the study
that got this type of tumor used cell
phones what's wrong here
no no here I think the study is flawed
what is the worst part about this study
29 cases sample size if you get 11 out
of 29 and say half of the tumors we saw
were attributed to cellphones that is
not a proper conclusion let's see number
17 ah okay
another Israeli study that talked about
Pardo gland cancers and salivary gland
cancers my note to this is read the last
sentence the blog says cause cancer the
data says no causal association so again
it's like it's almost criminally
ignorant how many times did you have to
miss the last sentence the conclusion of
the article to pick the part that you
want all I can say is everything that
you read on the Internet was written
that's the best I can say number 20 we
don't even have to go to the study here
let's check the study to make sure that
the quote is actually correct but before
for women yeah by the prestigious
publication in Dowie which sends me more
emails than I read their articles so
let's look at the abstract of all four
cases there are a case studies so
striking similarity how hard do you
think it would be to find for women with
a certain type of breast tumor there's a
lot of women in the world right and
breast cancer is one of the leading
causes of cancer in women
it wouldn't be hard to cherry-pick four
people to get the same conclusion you
want I mean there's another correlation
out of a hundred and eight billion
humans that have ever lived and have
been exposed to ionizing radiation all
of them died at some point at some point
yeah every human that's ever lived has
died and every human that's ever lived
had been exposed to ionizing radiation
perfect correlation no causation let's
see two more I think we have time for
two more this is kind of fun and I
cancer study all right let's just go
found elevated risk for exposure to
radiofrequency transmitting devices
I'm sure the author's do get mad but
what are you gonna do about some person
on the Internet right can send a nasty
letter to the magazine which might
reject it as hate mail okay on the blog
what does it say elevated risk for
exposure in the study I don't think I
have to make my point anymore we've gone
through about half of them I encourage
the rest of you guys to go through the
other half and to the people like this
Lloyd Borel I say check your facts what
you're doing is criminally incompetent
with the way that people are misleading
the public to get whatever pre gone
conclusions that they have from their
emotions or their funding sources or
whatever the reason to be by miss what
is it by misquoting facts
you're absolutely misleading people and
spreading false science cuz to me the
most exciting moments in science don't
end with the words I told you so but
start with the words that's interesting
so just because the study is that you
find don't support your predetermined
conclusions doesn't mean you should
reject them it means that you might have
to change your idea so on that note I'd
like to stop here we'll come back on
Thursday and go over the short and long
term biological effects of radiation and
look at some more garbage science yeah
I would just say go to the studies it's
very easy to say put a bunch of rats on
a cell phone charger turn it on and see
what happens I mean the data doesn't lie
the reason might be a little hard to
figure out yeah yeah so there I mean
there's another thing is when people
have a predetermined conclude this I
know it's a little past 10 but no one's
gotten up so I'll keep ranting so a lot
of this neo environmentalism going on
has the predetermined conclusion that
only sources of power light on the earth
like solar and wind that are renewable
and such are the ways to go and
immediately dismissed nuclear is not
part of the environmental solution
despite being part of the environmental
solution a large source of power that's
very efficient and doesn't emit any co2
it might surprise them to know that
manufacturing wind turbines is a major
source of radioactivity anyone want to
guess where rare or yes thank you rare
earth magnets a major cause of wind
turbine failure in the last decade has
been the gearboxes breaking down because
in order to extract power you have to
gear down those giant turbines by quite
a bit and those gears 300 feet up in the
air tend to break down they're hard to
maintain how do you fix it make stronger
magnets put in rare earth magnets that
electromagnetically harvest the energy
instead of gearing it down and doing the
same and you don't have mechanical
things grinding what are rare earth
magnets made out of rare earths
lanthanides which happened to be found
with actinides thorium whatever actinium
exists radium uranium things with
similar chemistry what do you do when
you extract the rare earths that you
need from the rare earth or you ditch
the remains which are concentrated
sources of these radioactive byproducts
we're the most radioactive I'm sorry
we're the most rare earth magnets come
from China
pause China's record on environmental
practices
spotty at best yeah so again one of
those things where people say oh wind
power has absolutely no effect on the
environment check the radioactivity of
making windmills I don't know if the
Sierra Club would listen I have heard
murmurs or rumors of them coming around
the idea of nuclear power there's an
article that said they switched
positions then there was a counter
article followed a day later that says
no that was a rogue actor they don't
reflect the views of the Sierra Club the
problem is with all these neo
environmentalists and cell phones cause
cancer people and food irradiation is
evil people you'll find them
cherry-picking data to support the
conclusion that they already felt they
wanted and when confronted with
overwhelming evidence to the contrary
they don't change their view and that to
me is the best thing about science if
you prove to me that you're wrong I will
say thank you not so there you go all
right I'll see you guys on Tuesday
you